charla que vamos a hablar de tendencias
y esta de las tendencias siempre nos
lleva al mundo de la moda y nosotros
queremos salir nos dáis radicalmente
para hablar de las tendencias ese
sentido amplio de las tendencias
sociales y por eso quería empezar con
esta foto que claramente es una de las
imágenes más impactantes del siglo 20
ella es kim phuc la llamada niña del
napalm fue un marco un antes y un
después en la guerra del vietnam y las
casualidades de la vida hicieron que
hace apenas tres años tuviera la
oportunidad de estar con ella
increíblemente pero es ella
el que está a su izquierda es el
fotógrafo que le hizo la foto y el que
le salvó la vida finalmente
la verdad es que cuando te cuentan esa
historia de lo que pasó de lo que sufrió
de lo que vivió esa niña el cuerpo te
queda
un poco descompuesto y la cabeza también
y fue en ese momento cuando digamos que
la cabeza empezó a empezar a dar la
sensación de que tenía que hacer dos
cosas que no había hecho la primera es
trabajar mi pasión de alguna forma desde
otro punto de vista
si ella fue capaz de encontrar su pasión
a pesar de todo lo que le había pasado y
ahora se dedica a dar conferencias
internacionales de motivación
precisamente ya por todo el mundo
cualquiera podemos hacerlo y la segunda
que las guerras además de hacerlas con
armas que matan podemos hacerlas con
armas que crean y en definitiva eso es a
lo que me dedico desde hace casi 20 años
o casi ya no hace 20 años
y así nació la consultora que tenemos
ahora que se llama stem by being
pero esto que de alguna forma nació en
ese momento
no nació porque si yo ya lo llevaba en
mi adn en realidad odio las armas odio
las guerras pero soy cazadora tengo mis
propias armas y mis propias piernas de
esas que hacen que crean negocios que se
inventen que aparezcan ideas que se
inventen proyectos constantemente que
busquemos que observemos a eso nos
dedicamos
cuando era pequeña yo no sé si recordáis
una serie que ahora parece ser que se
está reponiendo en una vez y empiezo ya
con las tendencias en una de las
plataformas tipo netflix hb o appletv y
demás que es esta que sois aquí que se
ha escrito un crimen'
la señora flecha y yo tenía
constantemente me ponía en la cabeza del
asesino no la cabeza ni de la policía ni
de la señora flechas sino la cabeza del
asesino a ver porque le motivaba como
para cometer el crimen y la segunda
parte cuál era la estrategia que iba a
seguir para escaquearse de la justicia
bueno con el tiempo pensé que mejor que
ponerme la mente de un asesino ponerme
la mente del consumidor que en todo caso
iba a ser lo mismo en la mente del
ciudadano y dedicarme a algo mucho más
productivo y mucho menos dramático que
ser que ser un asesino y así nació pues
éste maybin
este es una consultora de comunicación
que utiliza la filosofía de trabajo la
investigación de las tendencias a nivel
internacional busca lo que hacen
empresas lo que hacen instituciones lo
que hacen otras marcas para dirigirse a
su target a nuestro público y ver cómo
lo están haciendo con éxito para así
proponérselo a nuestros clientes
las tendencias están en todas partes lo
acabamos de ver hoy a lo largo de todo
el día lo que comentaba miguel con su
robot paquito lo que decía antes tatiana
con la no en la nanotecnología las
tendencias son el motor de la innovación
en unas ocasiones desde la evolución y
en otras ocasiones desde la revolución
aquí quiero pararme muy brevemente
porque no me da tiempo con estos minutos
que tenemos a pararme en todos los
proyectos pero si tenéis la oportunidad
de profundizar en estos que os voy a
esbozar de verdad que merece la pena sin
ley el proyecto 2020 espectacular se van
a convertir en la ciudad internacional
verde sostenible y conectada es un
proyecto que llevan más de 10 años
construyendo de forma transversal toda
la sociedad y que realmente merece la
pena estudiar colombia esto que veis
aquí ha llevado a través de la amazonas
el wifi a zonas que antes era
absolutamente impensable lo hemos hecho
con nuestros socios del país vasco'
alegría es un proyecto absolutamente
maravilloso
bilbao ha conseguido además del
guggenheim y toda la marca ciudad que
han ido trabajando el largo de todos
estos últimos años que la basque
culinary center' se convierta en el
centro pionero de la innovación
gastronómica en todo el mundo
tokio los niños en tokio no juegan en un
tobogán juegan con esculturas
interactúan con esculturas están en
contacto con el arte la mente les lleva
a la cultura es especialmente
apasionante ver cómo son los parques en
tokio y después este último proyecto que
yo soy estoy un poco obsesionada con
este tema todo lo relacionado con el
acoso escolar y el bullying estamos
trabajando mucho sobre este proyecto
lo hemos comentado con algunos de los
que sois maestros que sé que seáis aquí
maría el proyecto que iba por supuesto
finlandia ha sido uno de los grandes
pioneros en hacer un proyecto contra el
acoso escolar llevan han reducido con
este proyecto un 73 por ciento los casos
de acoso escolar desde 2007 fijaros 2007
estamos hablando de hace 10 años aquí
empieza a ser tendencia al acoso escolar
en finlandia llevan trabajando 10 años
contra este tema y en realidad sólo
tenemos que mirar lo que hacen ver lo
que están haciendo y ponerlo en marcha
aquí es a veces algo tan sencillo como
observar y hacer que pasión pero las
tendencias también están en galicia
amigos y clientes con sus cervezas de
pimientos de padrón es súper tendencia a
las cervezas artesanas las veis por
todas partes estrella galicia es una
cerveza artesana y bueno así no habéis
lo habéis probado pica esto es lo de que
unos pican otros no está pica un poco
pero probarla porque merece la pena
tenemos otro proyecto que al finalmente
no pusimos aquí pero lo podéis ver en el
porta del camino un súper logotipo de
ourense lawrence anilla marca territorio
uno de los primeros pioneros en poner en
marcha una marca ciudad no sólo en
galicia
bueno marca territorio en este caso sino
también en españa será el primero pero
no será el último y después la sanidad
en galicia tenemos grandes referentes a
nivel internacional salí hace poco
andrés beiras pero tenemos a diego
gonzález rivas están en todo el mundo
poniendo en marcha sus sus digamos
estrategias pioneras en el ámbito de la
sanidad lo podemos encontrar en todas
partes pero como me tengo que centrar en
dos me tengo que centrar en dos que
intenten de alguna forma recolocar en el
mundo en el que vivimos
qué es lo que hacemos para trabajar con
las tendencias
bueno los detox y la super foods estamos
absolutamente rodeados por los detox el
primer día que vimos una foto una imagen
con una celebrity con un envase raro
porque son raros
y con un zumo verde empezamos a decir
aquí está pasando algo recuerdo que en
2011 hicimos un proyecto un informe de
tendencias para una empresa y le dijimos
apostar por esto porque la super
alimentación con verdura y fruta
saludable va a venir bueno no nos
hicieron mucho caso pero os digo que hay
una empresa en murcia que se dedica y se
dedicaba en ese momento a recoger frutas
y verduras de sus huertos que no les iba
muy bien abrieron un departamento de
innovación y hoy en día facturan 180
millones de euros porque son los mayores
productores de esos zumos que veis en
todos los lineales de todas las grandes
superficies de todos los centros
comerciales
todos esos zumos los hacen ellos desde
murcia para toda europa es absolutamente
espectacular pero para que exista una
tendencia tiene que existir unos
antecedentes una base social que haga
posible que esa tendencia funcione
en este caso en el caso de los detox y
los super foods
son estos estos cuatro elementos fueron
un detonante clave para que realmente lo
veamos bien por todas partes no primero
la necesidad de romper con las cosas de
limpiar nuestro cuerpo de reparar
nuestras casas las casas son cada vez
más pequeñas queremos tener menos menos
muebles menos ropa la compramos y la
tiramos con mucha mayor facilidad
segundos cientos de noticias que alertan
sobre los casos de obesidad infantil por
cierto hoy leía una información el que
la obesidad no sólo la infantil por
supuesto la obesidad en general iba a
superar al tabaquismo en una de las
principales causas de cáncer ojo con ese
tema porque es clave para que surja este
tipo de tendencias en la tercera una
campaña tremenda contra la azúcar el
azúcar blanco ahora la fuga blanco
artista más azúcar blanco beige
tienen que meter en la cárcel o algo así
pues hay una tendencia a evitar las
grasas trans los conservantes los
colorantes todo eso va a continuar esto
es sólo el principio y 4 el interés por
el cuidado físico y mental el que no
haga yoga hoy en día está atrasado el
precio pero queda mal atrasado
y realmente hay una especie de cuidado
no solo por el cuidado físico sino
también por el cuidado interior por la
salud por la alimentación entonces nos
encontramos con este tipo de imágenes
por todas partes los famosos zumos los
famosos envases reciclables etcétera
etcétera los zumos digamos las marcas se
han invertido en zumos por esta demanda
social por esta necesidad de mejorar
nuestra alimentación y entonces estamos
saturados de medicación nos hablan de
que en madrid no se puede circular
porque estamos colapsados con la
estamos colapsados con la contaminación
vemos a los chinos con los con las
mascarillas de repente se nos colapsan
las arterias y aparece un producto a dar
alcohol se nos colapsa el colon y
aparece del producto activo ya estamos
todos colapsados y de repente empezamos
a ver una palabra mágica el detox que
viene a parece que solucionamos la vida
todo lo que vemos como detox lo
compramos lo vemos en las grandes
superficies en los champús vemos champús
detox ahora es increíble pero pero bueno
funciona porque se compra vamos a la
farmacia tienen cremas detox
no sólo han conseguido que la palabra
detox funcione con las frutas y las
verduras sino que han conseguido una
tendencia que nosotros llamamos
transversal que es que los super
alimentos de repente se conviertan en
algo absolutamente normal para nosotros
como hemos podido sobrevivir a la quinoa
alguien nos lo explica porque si yo veo
quinoa semillas de chía la avena la
espirulina la clase la lo de todos
estamos sobresaturados con este ya no sé
ya no sabemos que comernos yo ya no sé
si tomarme cuantas pastillas me tengo
que tomar el día de polvos de algún tipo
que supuestamente son naturales es así
es absolutamente increíble todo esto
sustituimos el original por la
melatonina que queda muchísimo más cool
y ahora nos pasamos a esta esta
tendencia que nos hace sentir mejor no
sé si funcionará porque eso solo lo
vamos a ver con el tiempo pero en todo
caso lo que sí funciona es que las
marcas están invirtiendo mucho en esto y
les está funcionando que finalmente es
un poco lo que lo que quieren
bueno todo esto surge porque hay una
serie de tribus que son muy famosas así
que vosotros ya lo conocéis porque
también estamos hartas de escucharlo los
famosos millenials que han venido para
poner en marcha todas estas tendencias y
para impulsarlas de una forma
absolutamente
espectacular tenemos a los veganos por
cierto tenemos también amigo también
cliente pepe vieira chef de estrella
michelín tiene uno de sus tres menús es
vegano esto era absolutamente impensable
hace cuatro años y ahora resulta que es
absolutamente normal ver en los
restaurantes babies
- para veganos por todas partes
bueno pues pues es una tendencia que ya
os adelanto ha venido para quedarse no
se van a ellos entonces apuesta por eso
las marcas de retail los grandes
superficies van a tener que cambiar su
posicionamiento de los lineales los
productos vamos a estar viendo todo el
rato si contiene las grasas saturadas
glass es ya lo vemos ahora yo el otro
día me encontré con una señora 70 años
con las gafas la lupa del ipad de
haciendo así diciendo esto tiene no me
lo llevo yo nuestro es tremendo pero
pasa eso y va a seguir pasando cada vez
más las marcas van a invertir en que el
consumidor vea la trazabilidad de sus
alimentos y aparte
y van a tener que seguir trabajando en
este proyecto sigo y cambio de terreno a
un tema muchísimo más duro y difícil
para mi igualdad feminismo y marcas
sociales estos son los antecedentes lo
ha comentado antes alguna compañera
tendría alguna discusión con ella sobre
al respecto de la neurolingüística sobre
este tema pero en todo caso estos son
los datos y esto ha provocado un
movimiento social de las marcas a favor
de las causas femeninas
era increíble que firmas como dior
firmas de lujo se pusieran a hacer
campañas a favor del feminismo era
absolutamente impensable pongo aquí la
definición de la rae del feminismo
porque es como yo me defino exactamente
así ideología que defiende que las
mujeres deben tener los mismos derechos
que los hombres sin más es una cuerda
floja para las marcas porque te puedes
pasar por exceso o por defecto y
entonces tienen que tener mucho cuidado
de no de transitar de forma muy
cuidadosa entre lo que aún no se puede
parecer mal y a otros les puede parecer
lo que llamamos ya el feminazismo que es
u otra tendencia que bueno daría para
otra charla y ojo con la rae que tiene
cosas también como estas que ya se
adelantó hay un movimiento en change.org
para eliminar esta definición yo ya por
supuesto lo he firmado pero en todo caso
me quedo con la otra definición que me
parece muchísimo más interesante
las marcas esta era la camiseta que os
comentaba antes de dior 500 dólares una
camiseta blanca todos deberíamos de ser
más feministas ni más ni menos yo os las
vendo por 25 cuando queráis si queréis a
salir no es de dior pero bueno no
valdría vender exactamente igual en todo
caso ralph lauren eso con su proyecto
ping-pong y con la recaudación dirigida
a las causas de la recaudación contra el
cáncer de mama y después por fin bbb a
una campaña espectacular podéis verla
con calma de empoderamiento femenino una
cosa que me llama verdaderamente la
atención y me apasiona especialmente por
fin una gran empresa apuesta por la liga
de fútbol femenino e iberdrola patrocina
por primera vez la liga de fuego ya se
lo merecen nuestras deportistas que
están año tras año consiguiendo los
medallas y venga con los juegos
olímpicos y venga con todo el número uno
en bádminton en pádel etcétera etcétera
tienen que hacer algo con éstas
os digo los que estáis aquí tenéis
capacidad de patrocinio de hacer
patrocinios invertir en el deporte
femenino no os vais a arrepentir y
además además vais a poder decir que
fuisteis los pioneros en poner en marcha
este tipo de tendencias y cuando
hablamos de igualdad y de violencia de
género tiene que salir con lo cual voy a
meter ahí un terreno un poco más
complicado pero solamente quería daros
un argumentario cuando buscamos las
tendencias
lo que hacemos es ver qué hacen otras
empresas que hacen otras instituciones
que hacen otros organismos que ya
funcionan en otros países y ver cómo lo
podemos aplicar a nuestra coyuntura
desde nuestro punto de vista lo que hizo
la dgt en su momento con las campañas de
concienciación de tráfico es algo que
deberíamos aprovechar para la lucha
contra la violencia de género en cuanto
en cuanto a concienciación obviamente
me podríais decir cuatro o cinco
campañas de violencia de la dgt pero
seguro que hay dos que recordáis la
primera la grandísima que sigue
funcionando hoy en día si bebes no
conduzcas y la segunda esa llamada que
recibe una madre a las dos de la mañana
teléfono humano en la que le dice que se
ha muerto su hijo cae el teléfono y esa
mujer sería también muere ese es el
punto de la violencia de género el
entorno el entorno es una de las claves
que con los que hay que trabajar todos
trabajamos en muchos proyectos de
violencia de género pero hay que
trabajar mucho sobre el entorno de las
mujeres que están siendo maltratadas o
que pueden ser víctimas de violencia de
género porque son niños los que le van a
ayudar a que tomen determinadas
decisiones son ellos los que van a hacer
que no tengamos que ver imágenes como la
que vimos hace cuatro semanas con ese
niño viendo como asesinada a su madre
jessica delante de sus ojos por su
exmarido eso no debe de pasar pero en
todo caso lamentablemente va a seguir
siendo una tendencia nosotros hace unos
años
para la ciudad de galicia un proyecto
para el 25 de noviembre el día
internacional contra la violencia de
género en el que poníamos el foco
exactamente lo que pensaba un niño ante
un caso de violencia verbal no era
exactamente violencia física pero era
violencia verbal y no teníamos recursos
se nos ocurrió una idea y llamamos a
icíar bollaín que como sabéis hizo una
película te doy mis ojos' era el año en
el que la estrenaba y con lo cual era
muy difícil que nos hiciera este favor
pero nos lo hizo nos cedió 20 segundos
del spot para hacer la campaña de
violencia de género aquí y me gustaría
que lo viera y lo que estás pensando
ahora piensas
como que no importa no importa lo que
digo no te importa nada lo que estoy
diciendo entre la boca
si no te interesa
se te trata mal maltrata te podemos
ayudar a superar o te húmedo 25 de
novembro día internacional para la
eliminación de violencia de género xunta
de galicia bueno poco más hay que decir
si te trata mal te maltrata
lamentablemente seguirá siendo una
tendencia a salir a la calle y con
pancartas en contra de la licencia de
género salir con camisetas ésta lo hemos
hecho nosotros intentamos hacer algún
elemento así visual en cada una de las
campañas para ayudar a determinadas
acciones de concienciación
vamos a seguir utilizando las rosas
vamos a tener que seguir con hashtag
apoyando la lucha contra la valencia de
género no va a parar aquí pero en todo
caso espero que pronto más pronto que
tarde realmente podamos hablar de esto
en pasado
y acá voy a por las tendencias y solo me
quedan dos minutos de charla que ya me
estoy pasando un montón pero bueno
la primera es que voy a aprovechar la
ocasión que nos ha dado t de esta tarde
estar aquí para presentar nuestro nuevo
proyecto trend y es un laboratorio de
tendencias que solo se va a dedicar a
eso a esta investigación a provocar
estas ideas a potenciar las a ponerlas
en valor a trabajar con nuestros
clientes desde la observación de todo lo
que pasa afuera para poner en valor todo
lo que se hace aquí
y como no vamos a hacer una inauguración
porque no nos vamos a dar unos pinchos
he decidido que os voy a dar dos ideas
que creemos que se van a poner en marcha
que se van a tener que desarrollar antes
o después que van a ser tendencia y que
quien quiera recoja el guante eso sí si
alguna vez a facebook de dix sobre estos
temas por favor acordaros de este
momento porque por lo menos es lo único
que nos vamos a poder llevar y son dos
brevemente
la primera esto que veis aquí muy
relacionado con los zumos detox el año
que viene vamos a estar todos por la
calle tomándonos un helado con frutas y
vitaminas esa va a ser una de las
grandes cosas que veamos por ahí todas
las fotos vamos a estar chupando fresas
congeladas va a ser increíble pero va a
ser así con lo cual si alguien tiene una
confitería una pastelería si cultiva
fresa se cultiva kiwis etcétera etcétera
y quiere desarrollar un proyecto
innovador por favor intentarlo con esto
echarle un vistazo buscad por ahí porque
realmente hay proyectos súper súper
súper interesantes
el segundo gran pretenden un poco más
complejo y para mí muchísimo más
dramático los que tenemos hijos lo
padecemos y lo vamos a padecer mucho más
me parece increíble y lo dejo ya como
detonante indignante que referente es
que para los niños son deportistas
actores y demás estén haciendo campañas
a favor del juego online y de las
apuestas online no me equivoco si os
digo que dentro de diez años estaremos
aquí diciendo
como paliar los casos de adicción al
juego y a las apuestas online acabamos
de ver una información hace tres semanas
apenas en galicia en galicia más de 10
mil 10.000 jóvenes adolescentes tienen
riesgo de caer en la adicción a las
apuestas online es una cifra
absolutamente escalofriante lo dejo aquí
recoge del guante trabajar sobre eso de
verdad merece la pena hacerlo aquí hay
dos empresas que se dedican a esto ojalá
pudiéramos trabajar con ellas desde el
ámbito de la rss para paliar este tema
ahora y no dentro de diez años cuando ya
no haya demasiada solución y ahora sí
que termino ahora sí que termino me
gustaría que de esta charla os quedaréis
solamente con una cosa la primera es que
todos tenemos una pasión y todos tenemos
la capacidad de observar
decía steve jobs que antes se mencionaba
pablo en su conferencia famosa
conferencia universidad de stanford
terminaba con una frase que es genial
que dice be hungry be foolish y esa
frase la hice mía y la traduje así un
poco a mi manera y decía que dice así y
la utilizo muchas veces para cazar solo
hace falta una cosa tener hambre y yo os
digo tener hambre de vuestra propia
pasión convertirlos en cazadores de
vuestro propio talento y recupero una
serie que ya veis que me gustan mucho
que también es de hace muchísimos años y
os sonará canción triste de hill street
que cuando el capitán terminaba su
reunión todas las mañanas le decía a sus
compañeros tened cuidado con lo que pasa
ahí afuera yo os digo estás muy atentos
a lo que pasa ahí afuera porque hay un
mundo de oportunidades lleno de grandes
ideas con lo cual convertiros en cool
hunters de vuestra propia pasión muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]